[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es ein Rezept, das sich mein Team gewünscht hat.
Ähm, Josh ist, müsst ihr wissen,
ein bisschen, bisschen süchtig nach Frittiertem.
Man sieht es ihm nicht an,
aber er wünscht sich schon lange wieder mal ein frittiertes Rezept.
Dann haben wir gesagt: Komm, okay!
Aber wir wollen es jetzt auch nicht übertreiben mit Ungesundem.
Deswegen haben wir uns gedacht,
machen wir Donuts, aber ganz spezielle, mit einer Füllung,
nämlich Apfel-Donuts.
Das ist, glaube ich, schon so eine etwas
genialere Alternative zu herkömmlichen Donuts,
denn man macht Apfelringe, ummantelt sie mit Teig
und die werden dann frittiert.
Ich glaube, dass die wirklich extrem lecker schmecken.
D.h., dafür brauche ich erst einmal
ein Ausbackteig, also ein Frittierteig.
Das ist ein Teig, den ihr einfach schnell zusammenrührt.
Es kann nichts schief gehen.
Dafür nehme ich 2 Eier, 200 g Mehl, 1/4 TL Backpulver,
80 g Zucker, 1 Prise Salz, etwas Vanilleextrakt und 120 g Milch.
Ja, im Prinzip …
Was soll ich dazu sagen?
Haut alles in eine Schüssel rein und verrührt es klümpchenfrei.
Was ihr hier vielleicht noch machen könnt,
wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt es echt gesünder machen,
dann verzichtet auf den Zucker und nehmt da eine Alternative.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich meine, es wird frittiert.
Vielleicht könnte man es noch im Backofen auspacken,
aber ich find, sowas muss einfach schmecken.
Und wenn ich so drüber nachdenke …
Meine Mama hat echt oft Frittiertes gemacht, z.B. Langos und alles.
Das könnten wir auch mal wieder machen,
so Langohr 2.0, weil es echt schon lange her ist. [Josh stimmt zu]
Also schön verrühren!
[Musik]
Der Teige ist fertig.
Den kann ich zur Seite stellen und hole jetzt einmal die Äpfel.
Am besten nehmt ihr da relativ große Äpfel,
wobei es im Prinzip egal ist.
Also nehmt einfach die, die ihr da habt.
Säuerliche Äpfel dürfen es gerne sein.
Jetzt habe ich hier meine Äpfel.
Da schneide ich jetzt erst einmal den Boden weg
und dann 1 cm dicke Scheiben.
Das könnt ihr jetzt entweder mit diesen Holzstäbchen machen,
also einmal oben oder unten.
Dann das Messer vorsichtig ansetzen,
aufpassen, dass ihr nicht abrutscht.
Ich drehe jetzt einfach den Apfel.
Das ist ein bisschen sicherer, als das Messer dadurch zu bewegen.
Dann habe ich eine gleichmäßige Scheibe.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme Ausstecher, damit die Äpfel einfach perfekt rund werden.
Müsst ihr nicht machen, könnt ihr aber tun.
Die Reste, die ich jetzt hier wegsteche
- daraus werde ich später einfach einen Smoothie machen,
denn das ist ja alles gut.
Das Einzige, was ich beim Apfel tatsächlich wegschmeiße,
ist wirklich hier … das da.
Ich esse auch das Kerngehäuse mit.
Deswegen mache ich später mit Sellerie einen richtig leckeren Smoothie.
Also hier einmal außen ausstechen
und hier innen mit einer Spritztülle oder einem kleinen Ausstecher.
Dann habt ihr wirklich so einen perfekten Apfelring.
Den wendet ihr dann direkt in Mehl,
damit da gleich der Teig gut dran haftet.
Dann habt ihr hier einfach einen perfekten Apfelring.
Den wendet ihr am besten direkt in Mehl
und dann haftet der Teig nämlich super dran.
[Musik]
Jetzt einmal schön komplett ummanteln.
Am besten nehmt ihr euch jetzt einen Schaschlikspieß,
stecht hier vorsichtig in den Apfel rein.
So könnt ihr ihn einfach besser mit Teig ummanteln.
Jetzt in den Teig reindippen.
Ich habe jetzt auch schon
Frittierfett in der Friteuse auf 160°C erwärmt.
Ihr könnt das aber auch auf dem Herd machen,
bei mittelhoher Hitze und dann von beiden Seiten ausbacken.
Ich drehe den so ein bisschen, dass der Teig gleichmäßig ist
und dann zack!
[Musik]
Es kann jetzt sein, dass sich das Stäbchen vom Apfel gleich löst,
aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Das ist ja praktisch nur zur Hilfe zum Eindippen da.
[Musik]
Und dann schön goldbraun ausbacken.
Den Stab könnt ihr dann am besten mit einer Schere
hier unten festhalten und vorsichtig herauslösen.
[Musik]
Also Josh, jetzt, wo war eigentlich grad so viel frittieren
- und ich habe jetzt schon noch bisschen Teig -,
sollten wir eigentlich Fritty Friday auf Fritty Monday holen,
denn ich habe noch ein bisschen.
Man kann übrigens auch die restlichen Äpfel einfach noch frittieren
Den Restapfel habe ich jetzt hier schon zu einem Smoothie verarbeitet.
Also es kommt nix weg.
Sollen wir ein bisschen frittieren? [Josh bejaht]
Willst du ein bisschen ausrasten?
JOSH: Kann ich was random frittieren? [Sally bejaht] Warte, warte!
SALLY: Hä? Was kommt jetzt, wenn kein Nougat kommt?
JOSH: Also. Halte mich für verrückt.
Ich will ein Stück Karotte frittieren.
SALLY: Auf Türkisch, bitte!
JOSH: Warum? Wie Türkisch?
SALLY: Ein Stück
JOSH: Havuç.
Was heißt „Frittieren"?
SALLY: Kızartmak.
JOSH: Was?
Das wäre dann havuç kızartması.
JOSH: Havuç kızartması.
SALLY: Ja.
JOSH: Okay, tamam!
Also erst Mehl, oder? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Warte, ich rette noch den Donuts raus und dann flippen wir aus.
Also wichtig ist beim Frittieren,
dass kein Wasser ins Frittierfett kommt!
Das ist wirklich …
Da kann eine Stichflamme entstehen.
Aber alles andere …
Also keine zu wässrigen Sachen frittieren!
Jetzt nicht Wassermelone oder Ähnliches!
JOSH: Oh stimmt!
SALLY: Ja! Ja! Damit …
Also falls es jemand nachmacht!
JOSH: Also auch kein Wassereis frittieren.
SALLY: Nein, nichts mit Wasser,
weil ansonsten echt eine krasse Stichflamme entsteht
und das ist lebensgefährlich.
JOSH: Das könnte auch lebensgefährlich werden, aber …
SALLY: Komm, probiere es!
Aber es gibt doch immer so frittiertes Gemüse beim Asiaten.
JOSH: Aber mit Teig?
SALLY: Ja, aber nicht mit Süßem, weil der Teig schon süß ist.
JOSH: Ja, aber …
SALLY: Ich finde es gut.
JOSH: Du muss auch mal …
SALLY: Brokkoli und Champignons
JOSH: Wow!
SALLY: Aber dann diesen Teig ohne Zucker.
JOSH: Ich finde, tatsächlich muss ich sagen,
SALLY: Ich finde es gut! Komm, ich mach's!
JOSH: Ich muss sagen,
ich finde Karotte eigentlich schon relativ süß, auch als Snack.
SALLY: Ja, ist sie auch.
JOSH: Von daher, vielleicht …
SALLY: Ich glaube, es wird gut.
JOSH: Vielleicht funktioniert es.
SALLY: Was haben wir noch? Ach komm, die Äpfel noch mit rein.
Aber ich glaube, die können wir auch so, oder? [Josh bejaht]
Was können wir noch? Nougat? Haben wir Nougat?
Wir haben schon noch Teig.
Haben wir Nougat da?
JOSH: Also wir haben was zum Streichen da.
SALLY: Im Kühlschrank vielleicht?
Und deine Karotte sieht gut aus.
Willst du sie auf dem Stab lassen?
JOSH: Ja, ich finde es cool als Snack.
Ich glaube, ich mache dann irgendwann mal
einen Stand auf Weihnachtsmärkten auf
mit frittierten Karotten.
SALLY: Warte, ich suche hier noch etwas.
JOSH: Ich wurde nicht fündig.
Oh, ich weiß, was noch frittieren will.
SALLY: Eine Dattel? Oh!
JOSH: Was ich aus deiner Deckung gefunden habe, habe ich kurz geklaut.
Ich würde gern eine Dattel frittieren.
SALLY: Okay.
JOSH: Sind sie schon entsteint? [Sally verneint]
SALLY: Oh, da könntest du jetzt eigentlich Marzipan reinmachen.
JOSH: Oh wow!
SALLY: Komm, ich schneide sie auf.
Marzipan haben wir im Kühlschrank links.
JOSH: Wir können 2 Datteln frittieren. Dann kannst du auch
SALLY: Okay, es tut mir leid.
Aus einem Apfel-Donut-Video wird ein Wir-frittieren-alles-Video.
JOSH: Ja, komm!
SALLY: Aber was soll's. Wir sind spontan.
JOSH: Wir frittieren alles, was ich unter die Finger bekomme.
SALLY: Oh Marzipan, Salted Caramel.
JOSH: Ja! Ich sag dir, das wird der neue Renner:
frittierte getrocknete Feigen und Datteln.
SALLY: Salted-Caramel-Marzipan,
Dann nehmen wir nämlich diesen hier.
JOSH: Ich rieche es schon!
SALLY: Das hier rein.
JOSH: Das wird richtig, richtig gut.
SALLY: Das da rein.
It's Fritty Monday.
JOSH: Guck mal, ich habe noch ein paar
Cornichons aus dem Kühlschrank. [Beide lachen]
SALLY: Es wär schon verrückt.
Ich tue mal die Apfelringe zur Seite.
Alpha-tier.
Darf ich dann aber auch von deiner Karotte probieren?
JOSH: Natürlich, ich teile sie mit dir!
Wow.
SALLY: So, die Datteln.
JOSH: Ich muss mal eins loswerden.
Es ist eine Seltenheit,
dass es so unordentlich ist auf deinem Arbeitsplatz.
SALLY: Ja, das ist echt so.
Es ist echt eine Seltenheit.
JOSH: Aber am Fritty Monday kann man auch mal Regeln brechen,
wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
SALLY: Aylin hat ihren ersten Arbeitstag mit mir
und denkt sich so: Was passiert hier gerade?
Wir haben nur gerade gedacht, wir haben so viel Frittierfett und Teig da,
Wir frittieren kurz alles,
JOSH: Ja, alles andere wäre doch Verschwendung, oder? [Sally bejaht]
Man muss mit den Ressourcen auch einfach verantwortungsvoll umgehen.
SALLY: Also man hätte auch einfach die übrigen Apfelstücke
klein schneiden, den Teig verrühren und …
JOSH: Nein, nein. Wir haben keine Äpfel mehr.
Die sind jetzt im Smoothie.
Wir haben einfach keine Äpfel mehr
und deswegen müssen wir jetzt Datteln mit Marzipan füllen.
SALLY: Boah!
Kommt ruhig rein!
JOSH: So, ich habe hier zwei perfekt gefüllte.
SALLY: Jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr, ob das ein Apfel oder eine Dattel war.
[Beide lachen]
JOSH: Aber hast du schon eine Dattel entsteint?
SALLY: Ja, ich habe 2 schon frittiert.
JOSH: Du hast schon 2 frittiert? Wow!
SALLY: Komm, die probierst du direkt!
Hi Muffin!
Ach, du machst es immer noch mit dem Stäbchen?
Ich mache es mittlerweile ohne.
Ich drücke sie so zusammen, dann rein.
JOSH: Du kannst am Weihnachtsmarkt …
Ich kann doch nicht einfach …
Das muss ja schon so ein Snack sein.
Guck mal, Cake-Pops.
SALLY: Oh, die Dattel war kaputt.
JOSH: Das habe ich nicht entdeckt. Ups.
Guck mal, Cake-Pops sind ja auch einfach nur Teig auf einem Stiel,
aber weil sie auf dem Stiel sind,
SALLY: Sind es halt cool.
JOSH: Deswegen müssen die Sachen ja auch auf einen Stiel. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Oh, mein Baby.
JOSH: So, eine Frage: Die Feige ist sehr, sehr trocken.
Hält da überhaupt das Mehl jetzt dran?
SALLY: Ich habe die jetzt alle ohne Mehl gemacht.
JOSH: Alle ohne Mehl? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Weil die schon so trocken sind.
Komm, hau rein, hau rein!
JOSH: Wow, das fühlt sich so falsch an.
SALLY: Das sind übrigens noch meine Feigen vom letzten Jahr.
Komm!
JOSH: Echt? [Sally bejaht]
Vom Feigenbaum draußen? [Sally bejaht]
Nice! Die sind voll aromatisch,
SALLY: Die sind richtig gut.
Darf mir eine Spitze wegschneiden?
JOSH: Ja klar. Ich wollte es in der Mitte durchschneiden,
dass wir beide probieren können.
Warte kurz. Sieht man das hier in der Kamera?
Also sieht schon interessant aus.
Und? Und? Schmeckt's?
SALLY: Ist okay. [Beide lachen]
Aber ich glaube, mit einem Salzteig ist es gut.
Ja …
JOSH: Ja, kann man jetzt nachmachen. Probiert es aus,
BEIDE: muss man aber nicht. [Beide lachen]
SALLY: Ich würde sagen, die Dattel probieren wir jetzt noch
und dann machen wir mit den Apfelringen weiter, oder? [Josh bejaht]
JOSH: Sorry, dass ich so ein bisschen dein Video unterbrochen habe.
SALLY: Nein, ich finde es gut. Ich mag das so spontan.
Also das hier sind die Äpfel.
Die können wir mit Zimt-Zucker bestreuen.
Wo habe ich Zimt-Zucker? Hier!
Da verrät, dass ich das vorhin schon gemacht habe.
JOSH: Vielleicht ist es auch nicht der erste, den ich nasche.
Man weiß es nicht.
SALLY: Ah!
JOSH: Ah! Heiß!
SALLY: Der ist noch zu heiß.
Hier ist die Feige und die Datteln müssen wir noch probieren.
JOSH: Auf die Feige bin ich echt gespannt.
SALLY: Boah, die Marzipanfüllung!
JOSH: Sie sieht schon lecker aus.
SALLY: Ja, ich finde,
wir sollten ein Video mit Ausbackteig drehen und dann dürft ihr
- oh, ihr könnt ja jetzt einmal drunter schreiben,
JOSH: Kommentiert eure Lieblingspasta-Sorte - nein, Spaß!
SALLY: Ihr könnt jetzt gerne drunter schreiben,
was wir im nächsten Frittiervideo frittieren sollen
und das machen wir dann.
Wir machen eine Version Süß und eine Version Herzhaft.
Es ist so heiß. Wie kannst du das essen?
JOSH: Weil es total lecker ist!
[Sally pustet pfeifend]
Wow. Können wir einfach hier abbrechen,
bei den Apfelringen und den frittierten Datteln?
Das ist mega lecker.
Okay, Karotte war ein Versuch wert.
Gut, aber frittierte Datteln …
SALLY: Okay, also wir machen eine salzige und eine süße Version
JOSH: Frittierteig und dann alles …? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Und ihr schreibt jetzt einfach drunter.
süß und dann die Lebensmittel, die wir frittieren,
und dann herzhaft und Lebensmittel, die wir frittieren.
So, jetzt würde ich sagen, räumen wir auf,
frittieren noch den restlichen Teig natürlich
und dann geht es gleich mit den Apfelringen weiter,
denn die werde ich jetzt gleich mit 3 verschiedenen Schokoladentorte
überziehen und richtig zu Donuts machen.
Das ist schon gut!
JOSH: Und weiter geht's.
[Rewind] Ich helfe noch beim Aufräumen.
SALLY: Mmh!
[Musik]
Ich nehme es einfach Kuvertüre in 3 verschiedenen Sorten.
2/3 der Kuvertüre wird dann über einem warmen Wasserbad geschmolzen,
bis sich alles schön aufgelöst hat.
Dann nehmt ihr es vom Wasserbad herunter
und rührt dann noch das restliche Drittel ein.
Und das mache ich jetzt mit allen 3 Sorten.
Ich habe jetzt die Sorte Ruby-Schokolade.
Ruby-Schokolade ist die 4. Schokoladentorte neben
Zartbitter, Vollmilch und weißer Schokolade.
Die ist ganz natürlich rosa, also nicht gefärbt
- kein Himbeerpulver, kein Farbpulver, gar nichts.
Es ist einfach eine Kakao … [Modemgeräusche]
… eine rosa Kakaobohne, wollte ich sagen,
Eine rosa Kakaobohnen, die dann durch ein bisschen Säure
einfach diese Farbe schön behält.
Es ist echt was ganz Besonderes,
weil man an der Kakaofrucht nämlich nicht sieht,
ob es eine Ruby-Kakaofrucht ist oder eine ganz normale.
Es ist schon so ein bisschen wie Trüffelsuchen.
Ja, kann man schon sagen.
Deswegen ist es auch eine Schokolade,
die ein bisschen teurer ist als die übrigen Schokoladentorte,
weil sie eben so besonders ist.
Dadurch, dass ich jetzt hier 2/3 zuerst schmelze.
und dann zum Abkühlen dieses eine Drittel dazugeben,
hat die Schokolade gleich die perfekte Weiterverarbeitungstemperatur
und bekommt einen schönen Glanz und keinen grauen Schleier.
Dieses Verfahren nennt sich Impfmethode.
Ich mache das jetzt hier bisschen parallel mit allen.
Dann habe ich mir jetzt hier noch verschiedene Toppings herausgesucht.
Da sind wir auch einmal ganz kurz dezent am Schrank ausgeflippt.
Ich habe hier diese Crispearls
- das sind kleine Kekse mit Schokolade ummantelt.
Ich habe noch diese Metallic Flakes.
Dann habe ich noch Pistazien.
Vielleicht nehme ich noch die Metallic Flakes in Bronze. Mal schauen.
Ich fange jetzt gleich einmal mit der ersten Sorte an
und das ist Ruby.
Ich tauche das jetzt hier in die Kuvertüre.
Und dann wird das Ganze mit Toppings versehen.
[Musik]
Kuvertürereste könnt ihr dann
in kleinen Eiswürfelbehältern einfach aufbewahren,
sie dann nach dem Erkalten herausdrücken
und dann habt ihr sie schön verstaut und könnt sie wieder benutzen.
[Musik]
Die Donuts sind jetzt fertig und ich muss sagen,
auf den ersten Blick - oder Josh? -
sieht es nicht aus, als wären das Apfel-Donuts.
JOSH: Nein, es sieht aus, als wären es …
SALLY: Donuts.
JOSH: Also normal natürlich nicht, die sehen nicht normal aus,
aber als wären es Donuts.
SALLY: Die normalen Donuts wären perfekter, fluffiger, luftiger, größer.
JOSH: Stimmt, die sind relativ klein. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Ich finde sie trotzdem schön.
JOSH: Aber ich bin sehr gespannt,
jetzt so mit Schoko, Toppings und Apfelfüllung
kommen sie vielleicht an die frittierten Datteln ran.
SALLY: Maybe.
Ich probiere Ruby.
JOSH: Okay, ich würde Karamell probieren.
SALLY: Kaum gibt es etwas Süßes, stehen alle an der Tür.
JOSH: Oh, okay.
SALLY: Mmh!
JOSH: Ja gut, vielleicht besser als die frittierte Dattel. Okay.
Mega lecker! Wow!
SALLY: Wie so ein Donut mit einer Hammerfüllung.
Ist ja auch ein Donut mit einer Hammerfüllung. [Beide lachen]
Ja, ein Donut mit einer Hammerfüllung.
JOSH: Die waren inzwischen im Kühlschrank, oder? [Sally bejaht]
Ich finde cool, dass der Apfelkern so ein bisschen frisch ist.
Vorhin, als wir so frisch frittiert haben, war alles so heiß.
Das war so …
Ich finde, …
SALLY: Stimmt!
JOSH: Wenn Frucht heiß ist, finde ich das manchmal komisch.
SALLY: Aber jetzt sind sie schön kalt.
JOSH: Das war bei der Karotte komisch, weil sie so komisch gedämpft war,
so wie Babynahrung, so heiß, ein bisschen …
SALLY: Die war ein bisschen seltsam und dann so ein süßer Teig.
JOSH: Das war strange.
SALLY: Aber die sind der Hammer!
JOSH: Das ist voll lecker!
Wenn die Füllung so richtig kühl ist und so saftig
- lecker, mega lecker. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Also auf jeden Fall nachmachen, ausprobieren.
Wie gesagt, wir warten auf eure Frittiervorschläge,
Lebensmittelvorschläge zum Frittieren.
JOSH: Wollt ihr sehen, wie ich alles aus der Küche frittiere?
BEIDE: Ja!
SALLY: Wie viel davon und wie lange. [Josh stimmt zu]
Okay. Also, probiert es gerne aus.
Das Rezept gibt es auf Sallys-Blog.de.
Übrigens habe ich die Reste …
Wirklich die Apfelreste, das Mehl und den übrigen Teig
einfach verrühren, kleine Küchlein ausbacken.
Wir haben leider nicht mehr so viele übrig, aber das ist so der Rest.
JOSH: Wo sind die nur alle hin?
SALLY: Die können sie dann auch gerne ausbacken
und dann habt ihr auch wirklich keine Reste.
So, also Kamera aus, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und wir verdrücken die jetzt noch.
Tschüss!
Ich freue mich auf unseren Frittiertag.
JOSH: Ja, ich fand, das war ein guter Einstieg in eine Frittiersaison.
SALLY: Wow, okay …
JOSH: Ja okay, wir übertreiben es nicht.
Wir machen einfach nochmal ein Frittiervideo. Tschüss!
SALLY: Ach übrigens, das übrige Frittierfett einfach abkühlen lassen
und dann wieder in die Flasche zurückfüllen.
So könnt ihr es dann entsorgen.
Entweder dort, wo man Öl entsorgt, da gibt es extra Sammelstellen,
oder ihr könnt es auch in der Flasche praktisch wegschmeißen.
[Musik]